[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le sky
échos votre nouveau rendez vous consacré
à l'actualité de l'économie locale dans
ce magazine bimensuel nous nous
intéresserons aux entreprises aux
entrepreneurs et aux salariés saint
quentinois qui participent à la vie
économique du territoire et pour ce
premier numéro nous sommes au propre et
mipim à paris un événement destiné aux
acteurs de l'immobilier d'entreprise un
secteur et vous le verrez dans lequel
est engagé saint quentin en yvelines
c'est parti pour le premier numéro du
sky échos quinze mille mètres carrés
cinq étages c'est le nouveau siège du
groupe bmw france à montigny le
bretonneux découverte du site avec son
président vincent aliments et la
directrice des ressources humaines
emilie aubert rencontre avec david
delattre il dirige la société alice adn
gestionnaire du restaurant la batterie à
guyancourt
elle a bénéficié du fonds résilience
pour relancer son activité
focus sur le partenariat entre deux
sociétés du territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines
airbus et scylla collaborent sur la
formation à la cybersécurité afin de
développer ce secteur
fixons nous pour objectif de sauver un
maximum d'emplois et d'entreprises à
saint quentin
ça doit être notre priorité par dessus
tout
[Musique]
c'était le 11 juillet dernier lors du
conseil d'agglomération d'installation
la reprise économique s'enclencher sur
le territoire et pour accompagner ce
mouvement saint quentin en yvelines a
voté un plan de relance de plus de 2
millions d'euros pour dynamiser
l'économie
on fait le point sur la situation dans
cette séquence décryptage
tissus
[Musique]
m
vous venez de le voir le fond résidence
fait partie de ces dispositifs
d'accompagnement de la reprise
économique parmi les bénéficiaires
la société guyancourt toise alice adn
les détails dans ma vie d'entrepreneur
avec son dirigeant david delattre
[Musique]
je m'appelle david delattre je suis
gérant de la société alice adn qui gère
le restaurant la batterie on est dans le
domaine de la restauration nous avons
huit salariés à guyancourt 78 notre
activité est basée sur le restaurant la
réception de groupe le traiteur la
restauration du midi la brasserie la
société existe depuis un an et demi je
suis arrivé ici il ya environ six ans
j'étais moi même serveur et chef de rang
pour d'autres restaurateurs qui exploite
et le restaurant et ensuite ils sont
partis et j'ai fait j'ai répondu à
l'appel d'offres et c'est moi qui ai
décroché la gestion du restaurant
[Musique]
il
l'année dernière on a fait six cent
cinquante mille euros hors taxes de
chiffre d'affaires par rapport à l'année
dernière on a perdu à peu près 50% de
chiffre d'affaires malheureusement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup
d'activités autres que la restauration
le midi
parce qu'en fait dans le restaurant nous
sommes dans un pôle musical dans lequel
nous avons des concerts nous avons des
événements tout genre est là
actuellement les concerts sont à sont à
l'arrêt les cocktails entreprises sont à
l'arrêt également
[Musique]
j'ai bénéficié d'une faune résilience à
hauteur de 20 mille euros les dix mille
premiers euros en fait vont partir dans
un plan de communication pour pouvoir
développer notre clientèle deuxième
partie de cette aide en fait va être
pour le développement de nouvelles
activités snacks et vente à emporter
pareil pour répondre un petit peu à ce
qui à la demande suite coco vide où les
gens veulent beaucoup de la livraison la
vente à emporter ce genre de choses qui
ne faisait pas donc qui va être
développée avec c'est avec cette somme
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines c'est un parc
d'immobilier d'entreprise de 4,6
millions de mètres carrés six grands
pôles économiques et une cinquantaine de
parcs d'activités parmi les nouveautés
le nouveau siège de bmw france à
montigny le bretonneux un site de 15
mille mètres carrés sur cinq étages qui
accueillera quelques 900 collaborateurs
un investissement de 100 millions
d'euros pour le groupe automobile
je vous propose de partir en immersion
sur ce nouveau site
[Musique]
vincent saly mon merci de nous recevoir
dans le nouveau siège de bmw france
bonjour et bienvenue dans ces
magnifiques locaux
alors pourquoi avez vous choisi de
construire ce nouveau siège
alors nous avons choisi de construire
d'investir de déménager de changer de
siège pour deux raisons principales la
première c'est que nous étions dans un
bâtiment qui avait 40 ans ne pouvait pas
continuer très clairement il n'était pas
aux dernières normes il était
indispensable d'avoir un bâtiment aux
dernières normes aux normes pardon aux
derniers standards écologiques et la
deuxième raison c'est que nous sommes
trois entités juridiques différentes en
france
bmw group france vous n'allez cité la
finale commercial mais aussi la banque
bmw finance est une activité de location
longue durée alphabètes et pour des
raisons de transversalité de synergies
au niveau des équipes il est important
de se retrouver dans le même bâtiment
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
ensemble ici à montigny il ya quand même
un symbole un derrière ce ce site
l'emplacement de ce site ça fait depuis
1980 que vous êtes installé à saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya une symbolique derrière ça il faut
rester sur le territoire de saint
quentin il est indispensable d'être sur
saint quentin en yvelines pour pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que ses clés c'est stratégique
parce que ses proches de paris mais pas
dans paris c'est ça permet de vraiment
d'être à proximité de tous les
partenaires aussi de haut niveau des
activités marketing et autres c'est très
central en france par rapport à nos
partenaires distributeurs
nous représentons 7000 emplois en france
mais il direct globalement ici et bmw
distribution mais aussi 6000 indirecte
dans les concessions donc ça c'est
indispensable
et puis très clairement
montigny-le-bretonneux saint quentin en
yvelines les les yvelines en général
sont très dynamiques
on est très proche du golfe on est
partenaire de la fédération française de
golf et nous avons le siège de la
fédération qui est juste à côté
donc c'est vraiment un endroit
stratégique où il était indispensable
pour nous d'être présents vous avez eu
900 collaborateurs sur ce siège et
justement on va aller voir comment les
collaborateurs ont été impliqués dans la
construction 2 siège de bmw france
[Musique]
emilie aubert bonjour bonjour départ
alors avec vous on va parler de la
conception de l'espace sur ce nouveau
siège
comment at il été pensé ce siège des
cultes et pour nous ce n'était pas
uniquement un emménagement aux 120
nouveaux sites
on a voulu vraiment en profiter pour
repenser tous nos espaces de travail
également tous nos modes de travail
du coup on a proposé à tous les
collaborateurs de bmt group en france de
réfléchir à deux aspects principaux
d'une part l'aménagement de nos
différents espaces mais également
comment on souhaite travailler tous
ensemble
donc vous pouvez voir ici on est sur un
open space type où les équipes peuvent
s'installer mais on a également d'autres
types d' espace avec des espaces plus
informelle où ils peuvent se rencontrer
donc on a des salles la cafétéria qui
est très sympa on a une terrasse
également où les équipes peuvent
partager un moment de convivialité mais
également travaillé on a des espaces
sportifs des espaces également de
relaxation un cabinet médical
voilà donc les équipes ont réellement pu
design et à leur manière et faire de cet
espace ce qu'ils souhaitent
le lab justement c'est tout
une équipe de travail a été spécialement
dédié à cet espace là et la volonté
était vraiment d'avoir un endroit où les
équipes puissent se réunir et échanger
entre elles
simplement pour pouvoir brainstormer
réfléchir sur des projets plus ou moins
stratégiques de manière à penser une
ovation et à se projeter sur l'avenir
merci les millionnaires merci beaucoup
[Musique]
du 13 au 15 octobre saint quentin en
yvelines organise un nid job dating
un rendez vous virtuel pour les
entreprises afin de proposer leurs
offres d'emploi d'alternance et de
stages et si vous êtes chef d'entreprise
hauts responsables de ressources
humaines et que vous êtes intéressé par
cet événement vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran pour vous inscrire et dans le
sky échos nous vous proposons aussi une
offre d'emploi pour ce premier numéro
c'est all tricks spécialiste de la vente
de produits de vélo running et triathlon
qui vous propose un poste de vendeur
dans son magasin à coignières c'est la
séquence
elles recrutent
nous recrutons sur notre boutique de
holt rixe à coignières une personne qui
serait en charge d'accueillir les
clients de les encaisser et de remettre
aussi à temps perdu des produits dans
les rayons la personne doit être assez
autonome et toujours souriante avoir
vraiment le sens de l'accueil du client
pouvoir l'orienter vers les différentes
zones du magasin pas forcément de pré
requis sur la formation une première
expérience dans le commerce sera un plus
le poste est à pourvoir tout de suite
sur un sur un cdi en 39 heures la
boutique est ouverte du lundi au samedi
donc je serai sur cinq jours de travail
nous serions sur une rémunération du
smic + heures supplémentaires et avec un
variable sur le chiffre de la boutique
pour postuler vous pouvez écrire à
coignières arobas autres x.com ou venir
directement en boutique nous déposer
votre cv votre candidature plusieurs
autres rendez vous d'abord la part ici
berwick le 30 septembre et le 1er
octobre puis horizon cyber le vendredi 2
octobre à saint quentin en yvelines
des journées qui rassembleront des start
up des pme des grands groupes des
chercheurs et des investisseurs pour des
rencontres des conférences et des
networking
l'occasion pour nous de vous présenter
une collaboration entre deux entreprises
saint-quentinoise dans ce secteur airbus
cybersécurité et scylla c'est la
séquence business kayes
[Musique]
la collaboration avec sylla consiste en
une offre de formation à la
cybersécurité
[Musique]
la société sylla utilise la cyberhaine
mis à disposition en mode saas par
airbus allait bien security
[Musique]
la cyber âge c'est un terrain de jeu qui
permet d'endosser sans risque
le rôle des hackers ou le rôle des
équipes en charge de la défense ou de la
protection des systèmes plus
concrètement la cyber ange permet de
faire une modélisation réaliste d'un
système d'information représentatif par
exemple d'une entreprise ou d'une
industrie et d'y jouer une activité
réaliste
[Musique]
airbus souhaité rechercher une pme et
aehi qui avait qui offrait une certaine
agilité dans ce domaine là notamment de
la formation pour airbus et de la
sécurité c'était également la
possibilité de travailler avec un acteur
qui met en place une solution innovante
avec un objectif qui est de former des
effectifs importants à la cyber faut
savoir que aujourd'hui nous estimons en
2022 un besoin d'un million et demi de
personnes supplémentaires dans un
domaine aussi vers sécurité qui sert à
deuxième objectif qui est également
celui d'augmenter la cyber résilience de
la france face aux menaces ciblées
[Musique]
on
c'est la fin du premier numéro du sky
ico merci de nous avoir suivis et
mission a retrouvé en replay sur notre
site internet sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]